لماذا في السلطه من الجماعه
لاني عارضت مقاطعه الاخوان سنه السبعه
والتسعين وكتبت مقالا لماذا قاطعه فالنت
في بيان الاخوان الذي برر فيه المقاطعه في
هذا السبب فقط
اذهب الى المحكمه معنى هذا كان في مدارس
داخل الجماعه وفي تصفيات فانا جزء من صفقه
التصفيات في سبيل ماذا تصفيه
من الاجنحه يدعي انه صقوري وانه ويريد ان
يتخلص من هذا لانه هذا شاب له مستقبله
ويترقى وصل للتنظيم الدولي وربما يصير
يعني مسؤول فربما ربما
افكرك بسبب شخص وبسبب افكاري انه انا لا
اؤمن الا بالاصلاح ولا اؤمن بالانقلابات
اذا هؤلاء الصقور هم كانوا يريدون
الانقلاب
هم هم السنتهم طويله فقط
الذي لا ياتي بنتيجه هؤلاء السياسيون يعني
ليسوسي يعني شوف انا عندي انا عندي بحث عن
الاسلاميه والسياسه
الاسلاميون في عمومهم بعيدون عن السياسه
تشتغل سياسي يعني بدك تحكي سياسي لا معلش
ما هو انا لما اكون بشتغل
يعني
السياسه جزء من الدين ولكن في علم سياسي
بحث يعني ممكن انا ابتسم في وجه شخص ولكن
هذا لا يعني انا معجب فيه هذا سياسه صح
دينيا انا ابتسم في وجهك وانا باكرهك بس
باللغه السياسه بيصير فانا اعتقد
الاسلاميين يعني هتحتاجوا الى جرعات من
الفهم السياسي للخريطه العالميه وخريطه
المنطقه وخريطه كل قطر بكثره لا يجوز
الظروف مصر على ظروف الاردن وظروف لبنان
على ظروف الاردن كل بلد لها موال اولها
ظروفها لم يكن لديك اي مخالفه
لا عندما فصلت
فقط بسبب المقال ما في شيء وانت لم تكن
تريد المقاطعه
انا لم اريد المقاطعه للجماعه اما انا
رجعت للجامعه فورا وان نعرض عليه ان اعود
الى البرلمان من قبل اشخاص في الدوله بس
انت تقول سابقا انهم كانوا
يريدون ان يشاركوا في الانتخابات ثم غيروا
رايهم كان في استطلاع للراي اكثر من 80%
نحن مع المشاركه من القيادات الاخوانيه
طبعا ولماذا غيره البعض اذا صار يحشد انه
ماذا نستفيد وهذا الصوت الواحد ما امر
ضدنا طيب من انتم في الصوت الواحد حسبته
على 17 مقعد وبعدين هل احنا مغالبه ولا
مشاركه سواء لنا 17 ولا عندنا 10 شو بتفرق
مادام بدنا نوصل صوتنا صوت واحد كان يهدف
الى القدس
عدد صفر
اذا بده يحجمني من 17 ل 10 انا بتنازل عن
العشره ولا بكون موجوده